this is a Fox News Alert president Trump
refusing to back down in his border
battle to build the wall Trump issuing
the first veto of his presidency to
overrule a resolution that blocks his
national emergency declaration at the
border the protection of the nation is
my highest duty yesterday Congress
passed a dangerous resolution that have
signed into law would put countless
Americans in danger very grave danger it
is definitely a national emergency
rarely have we had such a national
emergency therefore to defend the safety
and security of all Americans I will be
signing and issuing a formal veto of
this reckless resolution at Congress
vote to deny the crisis on the southern
border is a vote against reality
it's against reality it is a tremendous
national emergency it is a tremendous
crisis people hate the word invasion but
that's what it is it's an invasion of
drugs and criminals and people Congress
has the freedom to pass this resolution
and I have the duty to Beto it and a
very proud to be Joey so Mr gutfeld
watched this press conference in full
and I think he stole one of your lines
what'd he say said they were border
deniers even reality deniers I think
what do you think he's watching the five
maybe perhaps I don't think he watches
much Fox though you know when you look
back in an era growing up the 90s will
be grunge you know the 80s acid-washed
the 70s Jimmy Carter this year is gonna
be the wall because I feel like that's
every day we're always talking about the
wall it's part of his kind of like the
bigger picture which is safe at home an
appreciation of law enforcement so you
have a lot of the police there you have
an Iraq trying to eradicate the terror
threat and you have military the
military buildup so all these things are
part of one vision so he tends to see it
as that and other people see it as
fear-mongering
because that kind of belief can be seen
as fear-mongering you you want a strong
military you want a wall you want law
enforcement that's it oh my god you're
scaring people
so in
fortunately something that he believes
in can be recast as something wrong they
brought up a fact in there that I you
know made me think about the other half
of this story the number one leading
cause of death for people under 50 was
they said drug overdose one of the
officers said that there especially well
what about that you know the fault isn't
in the dealer's alone you know that the
trucks keep coming because we keep using
and I think there's there's a refusal to
admit that often the drug war doesn't
make things any better we're seeing this
with the opioid mess where we're trying
to reduce we're reducing the legal ways
to get opioids and that ends up in
overdoses on fentanyl which one of the
gentlemen spoke about the his son dying
on Fenton also it's we still have an
address maybe the underpinnings to this
story which is our desire for oblivion
that's right
people like to get zonked out of their
minds and you know great summary
speaking of zonked out of their minds
Nancy Pelosi says she is going to hold a
vote to overturn this veto but she needs
I guess two-thirds of the Senate to
uphold the override and that's just not
possible mathematically not at the
moment but what we saw was the
tremendous number I think it was 13
Republicans who voted with the 14 with
the Democrats in the Senate and so what
you're getting there is not a veto-proof
majority but you're getting in that
direction right and what you've got to
understand here is that you have
essentially a manufactured crisis long
at 58 lon remember I'm Zonta because in
Trump world I'm Zonk I so la allowed me
to speak okay but you get 58 national
security officials saying this is not
right don't do it you have in terms of
the polling in the country 64% oppose
the emergency declaration 58% opposed
the wall this is in close folks but it
four trumpets all about Trump and
Trump's political promises that you back
shop I'm amazing we're here those of the
national emergencies 5th company here
we're mostly Obama people and if you
listen to the actual sheriff's oh yeah
if you watch the press conference
they don't say it's manufactured they
say there's a huge crisis Lisa they
invited a lot of these congressmen and
women and senators to come down and see
it for themselves before they cast their
next vote well in Hwan you are your
zonked out my friend cuz even President
Obama in 2014 was talking about the
crisis we had along the border he did so
in the Rose Garden he talked about
traffickers bringing unaccompanied
minors across the border calling on
Congress to do something because we had
a humanitarian crisis that humanitarian
crisis remains today there's been
260,000 illegal immigrants apprehended
at the border 90 percent since October a
90% increase from last year ice is
giving pregnancy tests two young girls
over the age of 10 because of the amount
of rapes and sexual assaults that are
experienced along the journey so of
course we have any humanitarian crisis
the question is is a national emergency
the way to solve it I don't know but the
point being is that what we're seeing
right now is everyone exercising their
authority under the national emergencies
act President Trump has broad authority
declare a national emergency under the
Act Congress also gave themself the
authority to try to rescind that
national emergency president Trump has
the authority to then veto and then
Congress can try to find the votes
two-thirds in the Senate but your
override it so essentially everyone is
exercising the authority that we have
under the Act what you just said though
if this is not the Caravan this is not
like someone invading our country Lisa
we have a human show the caravan and
cultivate crisis look for a stop Juan
you were the first person yeah I say I
don't look I worry about but that's so
different than talking I wants an
invasion where you send troops and you
declare names people die no matter what
you want people die by the way never
never has any national emergency been
declared to get around the fact that
Congress won't fund this is an exception
then why did they run the act that way
Juan did Congress write an
unconstitutional act no no they say it's
never been done is all I'm saying but
they dragon in here taken I don't see
how this plays out in any other way that
it gets just tied up in the court yeah
it is it
tied up in the courts I think that there
were four additional states that signed
on to this lawsuit challenging the
emergency order bringing it to 20 and
you could get an emergency injunction
that stops this and it's tracks for the
time being but I listened one doesn't
recognize what's going on here with the
Republicans because they're not being
hypocritical
unlike the Democrats unlike Chuck
Schumer and Nancy Pelosi who basically
just sat back and let President Obama
violate the separation of powers let's
go through the list as The Wall Street
Journal editorial board wrote a blank
check on recess appointments
environmental and financial regulations
Obama care spending without
appropriations work permits for illegal
immigrants and more all rebuked by the
courts so that's why at least the
Republicans who voted against the
president are voting based on their
concern that the Democrats will then
turn around and abuse well that's my
point to do that so that what you're
saying is he shouldn't be where were you
guys when Obama was doing this nobody's
ever including Obama ever said I'm going
around the Constitution with Doc oh it
was a massive overreach with doc by the
courts because you know what by
President Trump at least so far doesn't
seem to be annoyed with these
Republicans cuz he hadn't calling them
names on Twitter yet maybe Mitt Romney
deserves it for that stupid op-ed and
blown out the bat actually he goes if I
wanted to pressure him I would have
brought the pressure because I didn't
need it because we had the votes but if
they want to see pressure they'll know
did pressure the only reason why we're
here is that the Democrats can't admit
that they want what Trump wants because
they can't admit that they agree with
them we're all talking about the same
thing we wanted enforced border but they
can't admit it cuz that means Trump's
right that's all this is about
it's petty political team sport I'm glad
you said that because I think Democrats
do want it but I think for the longest
time what you hear from Republicans
Democrats though but you're right thank
you here a history of Democrats funding
that's admitted about him as well let's
face it debated about him he is a large
character wand so it's hard not to they
have his campaign they have folk yes and
so they've made it about him well no he
said he came to because guess what
Republicans in the first two years
didn't didn't do this did they yeah
because they needed more votes in the
south Oh